Kristen Stewart offers a rare glimpse
into her past relationship with Robert
Pattinson I think I'm always gonna say
the same thing it's like I just you know
I'm like kind of I like my stuff mine
well not anymore
the actress covers the October issue of
Harper's Bazaar UK and inside the mag
she reflects on her life and former
loves including Robert did you get in
here the window the two started dating
after they starred in 2008 Twilight
together rob is a really good guy too
and while they went through years of
promoting the franchise together like
every single scene in this movie
culminates with some kiss of some kind
they remained private about their
relationship the only way that I'm able
to stay saying is to protect myself
quote when me and Rob were together we
did not have an example to go by so much
was taken from us that in trying to
control one aspect we were just like no
we will never talk about it never
because it's ours I'm never going to
talk about it and I know and it's fun
yeah it's gonna continue to be like why
like you're just you're almost trying to
make it more of a big deal but I'm
actually not because there's no other
way of playing it the couple split in
July 2012 after her affair with director
Rupert Sanders went public she and
Robert reconciled in October that year
but broke up for good in May 2013 the 29
year olds next public relationship came
years later and she came out as bisexual
in 2017 quote I think I just wanted to
enjoy my life and that took precedence
over protecting my life because in
protecting it I was ruining it it's bold
to do that it's great just to give
yourself to someone like that so yeah I
did that idea she added what you can't
go outside with who you're with you
can't talk about it in an interview I
was informed by an old school mentality
I have fully been told if you just like
do yourself a favor and don't go out
holding your girlfriend's hand in public
you might get a Marvel movie I don't
want to work with people like that